alors je demande pardon il ya un truc
que j'ai remarqué à la télévision quand
on passait comme ça des extraits d des
guignols aux hommes politiques
j'adore ça ça me fait marrer c'est
vraiment marrer parce que tous les jours
c'était tous les jours surtout sont
relativement bien parce que la
marionnette est assez bonne pour mains
c'est bon tu as donc je trouve que c'est
plutôt à c'est assez marrant tant que
mari mais pour le reste c'est totalement
à côté de la plaque parce que je crois
que vraiment s'il ya quelqu'un pour
lequel la culture est pas quelque chose
où il est arrivé le jour où il est
rentré au ministère et dont il est sorti
le jour où il est parti du ministère
c'est moi au moins je jetterai pas
exprès milieu artistique que je suis
intéressé de ça avant je continue après
votre femme a quand même déclaré au
sujet des guignols à l'air de moins
apprécié que vous a déclaré ils ont fait
un minable larbins con oui mais c'est un
peu ça on a fait ça à peu près avec tous
les ministres la culture oui et puis
jack lang est vrai que la nation que
ceux qui étaient passés la culture après
langues étaient là par hasard
catherine trautmann là on a dit apple ou
encore elle c'est pour l'enterrement de
césar il paraît qu'elle s'est rendue au
parc astérix est ce qu'il est il est
vrai que c'est une remarque très juste
le langue est resté 10 ans en deux fois
oui il est tout il a complètement c'est
la réalité
changer de dimension la politique
culturelle grâce au soutien que
mitterrand lui apporter c'est là aussi
une vérité historique et et est donc
c'est clair que les autres ministres qui
eux sont restés chacun deux ans quand
apparaissent comme des épiphénomènes par
rapport à l'homme et je crois que c'est
ça xp que ensuite ils ont tous été plus
ou moins douste-blazy a été carrée bien
sûr on a vu votre action la culture en
tant que garde des sceaux donc on peut
dire en vitesse était garde des sceaux
dessous gp12 95 à 97 plus fait chiper
avec une fuse d'instruction la culture
il y avait beaucoup d'instruction au
pluriel ça servait alors bon maintenant
il ya un truc aussi de votre action on
parle de votre action quand vous étiez
garde des sceaux il ya un truc effet mon
chez-moi rigolo c'est l'hélicoptère dans
l'himalaya je suis obligé de vous en
parler je raconte l'histoire en deux
mots un don qu'il y avait un procureur
cécile affaires du conseil général de
l'essonne donc c'est exact
xavière tiberi qui avait donc toucher
200 médecins des salaires fictifs de
monsieur du coin le procureur s'appelle
laurent davenas s'il est plutôt n'a pas
trop envie d'embêter madame tiberi et
puis voilà qu il part faire du trekking
dans l'himalaya se laurent davenas et à
sa place et nommé un hubert du jardin
quel est donc procureur adjoint 1 et par
intérim bien sûr en attendant que
d'avenance reviennent alors lui l'était
un peu moins sympa avec madame tibéri
que monsieur damas alors vous évidemment
ministre de la justice
vous allez dire si je me trompe vous
téléphonez à l'ambassade de france au
népal en disant faut absolument rien ni
capteurs dans la montagne pour chercher
des menaces pour le ramener la capitale
katmandou
ça n'a pas changé depuis mon époque et à
ce moment là une fois qu'on a ramené
davenas à katmandou on leur met dans un
avion il rentre à paris et à ce jour là
ils arrêtent toute la sphère et du
jardin retourne à ses chères études
dites nous que c'est vrai c'est
tellement rigolo l'histoire de ce côté
là je dis je dis que la question vous
avez commencé par milliers d'années la
question était est ce que le procureur
adjoint du jardin pouvait prendre une
décision contraire à celle que le
procureur en titre le jeu des menaces
avec prise avant de partir nous et la
question a été puisque monsieur
desjardins veut faire le contraire de ce
que monsieur des menaces avaient décidé
au départ de faire et qu'il avait donné
l'instruction de faire c'est à dire de
ne pas ouvrir l'information et
il fallait demander à monsieur damas si
oui ou non il était d'accord pour le
faire et je crois que c'est c'est
l'application stricte du code de
procédure pénale qui dit que
effectivement lorsque le chef du parquet
prend une position devant ses
subordonnés car le parquet et comme on
dit hier archives et non pas à prendre
une position mais parker a tant choqué
que l'hélicoptère soit 1 soit un moyen à
ce que vous avez de jeunes hélicoptère
sur un moyen extraordinaire j'en suis
d'accord mais que ce soit mais mais que
ce soit contraire au code de procédure
pénale c'est à dire à la loi ça je ne
suis pas d'accord si j'ai bien compris
si les mecs ont préférés ici
le procureur adjoint avait fait quelque
chose qui vous avez arrangez vous auriez
quand même essayer d'aller chercher une
autre procurant le vrai je n'ai pas
l'intention de faire quelque chose qui
nous arrange pas attendu le départ de
son procureur pour ferry imagine oui en
plus en plus j'insisterai pas mais c'est
vrai que c'était tout ça et c'est pour
défendre vous avez alors quand on sait
ce qui s'est passé après
c'est pas le problème le problème n'est
pas là moi je ne fais pas des choses
incendie dans l'autre pour les retours
d'ascenseur moi je fais les choses qui
me paraissent normales
j'ajoute ouchy donc je dis je c'est un
peu beaucoup
ouais j'ai pas ici a raconté des choses
vous vous dites quand même qu'il y avait
n'attendez-pas retourne à semble-t-il eu
un petit geste
attendez je dis non je dis simplement
que je dis quand je dis je c'est un peu
faux parce qu'en fait dans cette affaire
mais j'ai pas le raconter ici parce que
c'est certain que c'est la vérité je
suis là je vois là c'est tous bords dont
alors avec la paillade qui dit bachir à
quetta ce que je veux dire pour terminer
donc c'est que pour conclure la faire
parce que tous nos amis téléspectateurs
n'ont pas suivi cette aventure de
l'hélicoptère dans l'himalaya
c'est que daf n'a pas été retrouvée par
l'hélicoptère ec en revanche la sphère a
été financée par les fonds secrets de
matignon ça vous à bon port la nouvelle
prenez des trucs pour venir plus souvent
est ce que vous avez des questions parce
qu'on a fini lâche poser les questions à
poser à jacques toubon profitez-en
quand est-ce qu'il va chanter la bande
bas nous avons dû voyager faire chanter
les amateurs bon ben ouais on juste une
tout arranger un coup pas avoir un
appartement dans le xiiie
je vous réponds très clairement quel est
votre plat notre revenu si vous êtes
dans les plafonds vous avez droit à un
logement social
parce qu'on est à la mi-mars ce succès
pas le droit c'est pas parce qu'on est
journaliste au berry n'avait pas de
plafond alors sa chance